elle ne prend aucune chance ce n'est pas
un pied cassé qui allait empêcher jane
de venir dormir dans cette petite tente
pour avoir une place de choix tv on est
vrai que pour être honnête n'est
vraiment pas confortable je n'ai pas
dormi la nuit dernière je pensais le
faire et puis les canards dans les
tentes se sont mis à cancaner
bernadette christie aussi est arrivé dès
hier soir du canada l'albertaine ne
manque aucune des grandes célébrations
royal à londres il faut savoir y faire
dit elle
ainsi que pour avoir l'air joli dit elle
il faut être devant et c'est ce qu'on
fait j'ai serré la main de william et
kate et diana et charles deux fois alors
je sais comment me perdre il faut
arriver tôt soit nomades de
[Musique]
l'anticipation ici est contagieuse mais
ce ne sont pas tous les anglais qui ont
l'esprit à la fête
jim butcher n'a aucune intention
d'assister au fait du jubilé s'il
concède qu'on puisse souhaiter souligner
les 70 ans de règne de la monarque unis
ne le fera pas parce il garde toute sa
tête les antilles
[Musique]
le vieux punk a grandi au son rebelle
des sex pistols des clashs et des rames
hands le climat social pourri de
l'époque a nourri une saine méfiance de
l'autorité et des symboles dit il un
climat social qui ressemble beaucoup à
celui d'aujourd'hui selon l'éditeur du
magazine vive le rock
je suis fâché de voir qu'on dépense 1
milliard de livres dit-il pour célébrer
la reine alors qu'il ya tant de
problèmes aux pays et des gens ce moment
doivent se rendre dans les banques
alimentaires pour nourrir leurs enfants
ce serait plutôt autour de 28 millions
de livres sterling soit plus de 44
millions de dollars qui seront dépensés
au cours des prochains jours
je pense qu'on en a besoin plus que
jamais surtout après les dernières
années dit elle avec le confinement les
gens qui ne pouvaient pas se rencontrer
alors j'espère que ça va relever le
moral de la communauté et aider les
entreprises locales
samantha bailly conseillère municipale
pour rassembler la population autour des
célébrations la petite ville d'abingdon
a adopté la tradition singulière de
lancer des petits pains depuis le toit
de l'édifice municipal
chaque occasion importante est ainsi
marqué par ces milliers de petits pains
sucrés projeté sur la grande place
[Musique]
patrick brown et john crowley ils seront
aussi poursuivant une autre tradition
tout aussi ancien
je n'ai connu que la reine elizabeth sur
le tronc dans ma vie dit il pour moi il
représente une brique dans un mur qui
est très solide
les deux hommes sont crieur les
naissances les mariages les
couronnements les morts aussi dans la
famille royale c'est comme ça qu'ils les
annonces
si ça ne vous plaît pas dit s'il vous
pouvez toujours regarder la télé et la
plupart des gens adorent la couleur la
cérémonie c'est comme la monarchie elle
même c'est la tradition c'est la couleur
c'est une cérémonie qu'on ne trouve
nulle part ailleurs qu on y
pratique elle contribue un phénomène
tout aussi anglais quoique beaucoup plus
récents elle a choisi de combiner sa
passion pour le crochet à son
attachement pour la famille royale elle
a consacré trois semaines à la création
de ce qu'on appelle ici un top et un
bonnet pour les boîtes aux lettres
depuis quelques jours il coiffe des
boîtes un peu partout pis
il ya sans doute une forme de rivalité
amicale dit elle et que les gens
essaient de se surpasser de faire
toujours plus grand et mieux
de retour sur le mall à londres quatre
générations de coupe qui se massent pour
un avant goût de ce qui est annoncé
comme la parade de toute une génération
albert le patriarche est
particulièrement ému ahmad ali
à 94 ans il mesure sans doute mieux que
quiconque l'ampleur historique de
l'événement le dernier du genre pour lui
mais aussi pour sa petite fille et ses
arrière petits enfants croit-il le vieil
homme pense qu'après elisabeth ce sera
le début de la fin pour la monarchie
j'imagine qu'il faut savoir passer à
autre chose dit il mais il ne veut
surtout pas y être pour le voir c'est à
la fête qu'il veut assister
[Applaudissements]
si mario bédard radio canada non